[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halallweg guten Abend und willkommen
Norbert Lehmann ist auch dabei mit dem
Nervenkitzel Handball Auftritt von
gestern Abend schönen guten Abend auch
von mir schauen wir auf die
Nachrichtenthemen von heute Flagge
zeigen gegen Rechtsextremismus allein in
Hamburg demonstrieren
50.000 weitere Proteste sind am
Wochenende
geplant schneller zum deutschen Pass der
Bundestag erleichtert die Einbürgerung
für Zuwanderer ihren bisherigen Pass
können sie auch
behalten letzter Gruß für den
[Musik]
Kaiser Deutschland nimmt Abschied von
der fußballikone Franz
Beckenbauer Münster Kiel Kaufbeuren
Bielefeld Braunschweig Bochum Dortmund
Erfurt Leipzig Kemnitz Heidelberg
München die Protestwelle gegen
Rechtsextremismus und die AFD weitet
sich immer mehr aus das Portal zusammen
gegen Rechts listet übers Wochenende
insgesamt 90 Kundgebungen auf alle
ausgelöst durch die Enthüllungen über
ein Geheimtreffen von Rechtsradikalen
allein in Hamburg kamen heute 50.000
Menschen Martin
nien ursprünglich gemeldet hatten die
Veranstalter 2000 teilnehmende gekommen
sind weit mehr als 50.000 hamburg steht
auf das Motto gegen Rechtsextremismus
und neonazisstische Netzwerke die
Botschaft an die AFD und ihre rechten
Netzwerke ist wir sind die Mehrheit und
wir sind stark weil wir geschlossen sind
und weil wir entschlossen sind
christlicher Glaube und völkisches
Denken passen nicht zusammen genauso
wenig wie Kreuz und Haken Kreuz auch im
thüringischen jener gehen die Menschen
auf die Straße es sind mehr als 3000
dort unter ihnen auch der
Ministerpräsident in welchem Land wollen
wir leben in einem Land in dem es nicht
auf Hautfarbe Haarfarbe Herkunft
Abstammung auch nicht auf Religion oder
Atheismus ankommt in Hamburg hatte die
AFD mit einem Trick eine Demonstration
auf dem Rathausmarkt verhindert durch
eine spontan einberufene Fraktion ung
galt um das Rathaus eine Bannmeile
Begründung der AFD es geltet Zitat die
Herzkammer der Demokratie vor linken
Extremisten zu schützen wir erleben
gegenwärtig Weimarer Verhältnisse was
die Menschen in Hamburg offensichtlich
als Provokation verstanden die
zusätzlich motiviert hat ja ich fin es
ein tolles Zeichen dass gerade deshalb
vielleicht auch noch mal deutlich mehr
Menschen hierher gekommen sind um zu
zeigen dass Sie damit nicht
einverstanden sind na ja das ist Banane
ehrlich gesagt um uns zu ärgern also das
ist mich spelchen ja und ich finde es
sieht viel schöner aus wenn wir hier
alle über jungf verteilt stehen als auf
dem kleinen radusmarkt da weil zu viele
demonstrierende gekommen waren wurde die
Veranstaltung aus Sicherheitsgründen
vorzeitig beendet was mehrere tausend
von ihnen nicht davon abhielt
schließlich doch noch vor das Rathaus zu
kommen in Bochum geht's in diesen
Minuten los siana Becker wer sammelt
sich da wie ist die
Atmosphäre die Stimme in Bochum ist
friedlich die Demonstration hat sehr
lautstark begonnen gerade mit Musik und
es soll jetzt auch eine Kundgebung
folgen hier auf dem Bahnhofsvorplatz in
Bochum eine Privatperson hatte die
Demonstration angemeldet es waren
ursprünglich rund 1000 Teilnehmer
erwartet also die Teilnehmerzahl war
schon auf 1000 hochgestuft worden
aufgrund der Erfahrungswerte der
vergangenen Demonstration in der letzten
Woche die Teilnehmenden hier werden
gleich weiterziehen zum Schauspielhaus
Bochum wo noch eine Kundgebung
stattfinden wird und es haben sich hier
zahlreiche Organisationen und auch
Parteien
angeschlossen ja dem Aufruf heute zur
Demonstration gegen Rassismus gegen
Rechtsextremismus und gegen die AFD das
heute ist auch in NRW ein Auftakt zu
einem
demonstrationswochenende in ja in ganz
Deutschland danke schön Juliana Becker
war das live aus
buchum zugewanderte sollen künftig
schneller einen deutschen Pass bekommen
das hat der Bundestag heute beschlossen
statt nach 8 Jahren kann man schon nach
5 Jahren Aufenthalt eingebürgert werden
wer besonders gut integriert ist sogar
schon nach 3 Jahren nicht eingebürgert
wird wer etwa wegen Rassismus
Antisemitismus oder Fremdenfeindlichkeit
aktenkundig ist grundsätzlich soll die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft nur erhalten
wer den Lebensunterhalt selbst
bestreiten kann Andrea Maurer
nachdem der Bundestag gestern
Abschiebungen verschärft hat
beschleunigt er heute Einbürgerungen die
Innenministerin spricht von
Wertschätzung für die die sich hier
einbringen und der Chance Fachkräfte zu
gewinnen deswegen werbe ich noch mal
angesichts der aktuellen Lage wo von
ganz rechts außen Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund gerade
wirklich schlimm ausgegrenzt werden noch
mal darum dass man dieses
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht wirklich als
Chance auch ansieht auch doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft soll möglich sein wie
viel Einbürgerung bedeutet Macht die
grüne Abgeordnete shahina
gambierkler für mich hat sich das Jahr
indem ich 18 wurde fest in meiner
Erinnerung verankert das lag allerdings
weniger an meinem Geburtstag sondern
viel mehr daran dass ich mit 18 endlich
eingebürgert wurde nachdem ich bereits
15 Jahre in Deutschland gelebt hatte es
nicht nur darum geht ein zu erleichtern
sondern auch zu verhindern etwa im Fall
von mehr Ehe Antisemitismus Rassismus
betont die FDP wer Deutscher werden will
muss ich ausdrücklich und dezidiert
explizit zur freiheitlich demokratischen
Grundordnung bekennen schaffe Kritik
dennoch aus der Union weil wir den Pass
auf Ewigkeit verleihen gilt der gute
alte deutsche Satz drum prüfe wer sich
ewig bindet und je kürzer die Fristen
sind mit fünf oder gar 3 Jahren kann
keine Verwurzlung in unserem Land
stattgefunden haben die AFD spricht von
Zitat turboeinbürgerungen die stolze
Staatsbürgerschaft soll verramscht
werden an quasi alle die sich fünf bis Z
D Jahre in Deutschland aufgehalten haben
das Gesetz muss nun noch durch den
Bundesrat es war ein dicker Dämpfer für
die Ampel als das
Bundesverfassungsgericht im November
Teile des Haushalts kippte und die
Regierung plötzlich viel weniger Geld
zur Verfügung hatte und kräftig sparen
musste jetzt aber steht der Haushalt für
dieses Jahr gestern Abend einigte sich
der zuständige Ausschuss Bundestag und
Bundesrat müssen noch zustimmen
erleichtert wurde das Ganze weil noch
einige Milliarden Euro auftauchten
Andreas
küast es ist das gefürchtetste Treffen
des politischen Jahres in der
sogenannten
haushaltsbereinigungssitzung Teilen
drinnen die Abgeordneten das noch
verfügbare Geld auf und warten draußen
die Minister und ihre Beamten darauf wie
schlimm es wird dass
wohnungsbauministerin Geiwitz sogar eine
Milliarde zusätzlich bekommt dass die
Agentur für Arbeit mit 1,5 Milliarden
mehr rechnen darf liegt auch an einem
überraschungspfund 6,3 Milliarden Euro
die vergangenes Jahr nicht ausgegeben
wurden hat uns das geholfen ja
entscheidend nein entscheidend ist für
die FDP dass auch die Fraktion des
Parlaments
entschieden haben nicht eine Ausnahme
von der Schuldenbremse in Anspruch zu
nehmen entscheidend für SPD und Grüne
dass eine Ausnahme von der
Schuldenbremse möglich bleibt etwa für
die Ukraine wenn es im weiteren Verlaufe
des Jahres dazu kommt dass es eine
Verschlechterung der Ukraine gibt eine
weitere Verschlechterung dann werden wir
mehr finanzieren und mehr machen müssen
beim heftig umstrittenen Agrardiesel
hält die Ampelkoalition an der
Abschaffung der Steuerentlastung fest
sie wäre nicht nötig gewesen kritisiert
die
AFD wenige ganz wenige Positionen hätten
den Agrardiesel für mehrere Jahre
finanziert man hätte sich die ganzen
Demos hier sparen können auch die Union
kritisiert die Streichung des
Steuervorteils die Landwirtschaft und
ländliche Räume waren offensichtlich das
Schlachtopfer was diese Bundesregierung
gebracht hat und wir brauchen wieder
eine starke Stimme für die
Landwirtschaft unter heftigem Spardruck
und unter heftigem Streit hat sich die
Ampelkoalition auf einen Haushalt
geeinigt 145 Tage und einen Abend hat
sie
gebraucht die Grüne Woche in Berlin auch
diesmal ist sie die Gelegenheit für
Besucher internationale Spezialitäten zu
probieren oder Trends bei Lebensmitteln
nachzuspüren es geht aber wegen der
derzeit Demonstrierenden Bauern etwas
politischer zu als sonst Agrarminister
östemier versprach ihnen von Seite
weniger Zickzack und mehr Planbarkeit
Bauern Präsident ru kündigte trotzdem
weitere Proteste für die nächste Woche
an allerdings eher nadelstichartig wer
einfach nur landwirtschaftliche Produkte
genießen will die Grüne Woche läuft bis
über nächsten
Sonntag um weitere Streiks bei der Bahn
abzuwenden hat das Unternehmen der
lockführergewerksschaft GDL ein neues
Angebot vorgelegt es sieht gestaffelt
Lohnsteigerungen bis fast 10% vor ab
2026 bietet die Bahn an eine Stunde
weniger zu arbeiten bei vollem
Lohnausgleich oder in normalem Umfang
für dann noch mal 2,7% mehr Geld die GDL
will das Angebot nun
prüfen nicht überraschend aber
alarmierend für die Wirtschaft so die
Bilanz der DAK zum Krankenstand
2023 im Schnitt meldete sich laut
Krankenkasse jeder Arbeitnehmer 20 Tage
krank ein Rekordhoch das zweite Jahr
infolge die meisten Fehltage gab es bei
Menschen in der Altenpflege und Kita
Beschäftigten häufigste Ursache
Erkältungskrankheiten gefolgt von
Krankheiten des
muskelskelettsystems und psychischen
Diagnosen heute auf den Tag genau vor
vier Monaten besiegelte sich das
Schicksal von rund 100.000 Armenier in
Bergkarabach denn am 19 September
eroberte Aserbaidschan die Region im
Kaukasus fast alle dort wohnenden
Armenier sahen sich gezwungen zur Flucht
das Besondere an dem Konflikt
völkerrechtlich gehörte die
selbsternannte Republik Bergkarabach
schon lange zu Aserbaidschan nur lebten
dort traditionell vor allem Armenia wie
geht es Ihnen jetzt nach der Flucht
Richtung Armenien Nina
Niebergall es sind die armen Vororte der
armenischen Hauptstadt irivan in denen
die meisten Flüchtlinge aus berkarabach
en so wie Mar Gabri und ihre Familie
doch es gibt kaum Arbeit für sie nur
diese typisch armenischen Pfannkuchen
sichern ihr
Überleben der Ofen ist das einzige was
ich von meinen Sachen mitgebracht habe
damit ich arbeiten kann ich muss wieder
Geld verdienen um die Familie zu
entlastenp Vergangenes
J
Aabach die gesamte
Bevölkerung viele Menschen die das
kleine Armenien integrieren muss die
Regierung unterstützt die Flüchtlinge
finanziell doch sie finden nur schwer
Wohnungen sind verstreut im Land
Nachbarschaften Familien zerrissen Marin
Bruder ist in einem der Bergkarabach
Kriege gestorben ihr Mann hat eine
Behinderung die ganze Familie lebt von
den Pfannkuchen die Söhne helfen
mit
er fühlt sich wohl in Armenien aber an
dauerhaften Frieden glaubt er
nicht ich will nicht schon wieder Krieg
aber ich weiß dass es einen geben wird
und wir brauchen ihn auch damit wir
Bergkarabach zurückerobern und uns dort
eine Zukunft aufbauen
können Aserbeidschan bleibt der totfeind
Berg Karabach die Heimat in die auch
Marin zurückkehren will das lässt sie
durchhalten wenn es kaum Hoffnung
gibt Angela Merkel Papst Franziskus und
der ukrainische Präsident selenski haben
ihn schon in diesem Jahr geht der aener
Karlspreis an den Präsidenten der
Europäischen rabbinerkonferenz Pinchas
Goldschmidt und an die jüdischen
Gemeinden in Europa als Signal gegen
Antisemitismus die Jury lobte vor allem
goldschmits Einsatz für die
Verständigung zwischen den Religionen
wir blicken zum Mond da ist es Japan vor
wenigen Stunden gelungen eine unbemannte
Sonde zu landen jetzt gibt es allerdings
Probleme mit der Stromversorgung der
Sonde noch ist unklar ob sie
weiterarbeiten kann das unbemannte minir
Raumschiff soll auf dem Mond Gestein
untersuchen und nach Wasser forschen
bisher waren nur den USA der Sowjetunion
China und Indien Mondlandungen
gelungen heute Nachmittag in der
Münchner Allianz Arena rund 30.000 Fans
Angehörige und Freunde nehmen Abschied
von Franz Beckenbauer als Glücksfall für
uns alle würdigt ihn der Bundespräsident
der Präsident des FC Bayern sagt Franz
glaubte fest daran dass der Tod nur eine
Etappe ist dass er Teil von uns bleibt
aus München Petra
Neubauer Zeit um Lebwohl zu sagen
Weggefährten bringen Rosen ins Stadion
begleitet von stenor jas
kaufn tion ale auftagt einer
außergewöhnlichen Gedenkfeier 10usende
sind in die Allianzarena gekommen eine
letzte Verneigung vor einer
Fußballlegende er lebt nicht mehr aber
für uns lebt er immer weiter das war das
schönste Geschenk was wir uns machen
können heute dass wir dabei sind
und Abschied nehmen für mich war er der
Größte ist er der größte und wird immer
der größte bleiben nicht nur die Fans
auch Prominente aus Politik Gesellschaft
und Sport sind dem Ruf aus München
gefolgt finden berührende Worte wohin
ich immer kam auf allen Kontinenten
kannte und kennt man Franz
Beckenbauer als diplomatisches
Naturtalent wurde er zum beliebtesten
Botschafter unseres Landes er hat sich
um unser Land verdient gemacht auf den
großen stadionleinwänden lässt ein
filmenau
noch einmal vorbeizehen in all seinen
Facetten auch mit kurzen Ausflügen in
die Werbe und
gesangsbranche schmeckt prima und so
richtig kräftig müssen Sie
probieren war immer ein Mensch der
bescheiden war der nie den großen Max
herausgespielt hat der für uns
Mitspieler immer hil Hilfe gestellt hat
wenn ich auf Platz nichthr er wusste
wohin wir im Ball beim Franz war er ganz
sicher
ein Viertel Stunden dauert dieser
Abschied vom Kaiser zusammenfassen lässt
es sich in einfachen Worten danke
Franz ja danke Franz er hätte sicher
auch seine Freude an dem deutschen
Handballteam gehabt ganz knapp war das
gestern aber Deutschland besiegt Island
ja wie du schon sagst knapp war es
erstens
2624 zweitens verdient ein echte
Willensleistung aber drittens nicht
gerade glänzend der schwächste
Turnierauftritt des DB Teams bislang
dafür aber die stärkste Leistung eines
Mannes Torwart Andreas
Wolf auch am Tag danach muss der
Bundestrainer viele Fragen zum Phänomen
im deutschen Tor beantworten Andreas
Wolf mit gleich zwei gehaltenen 7 met in
den
Schlussminuten als habe der 32-Jährige
hellseeherische Fähigkeiten und stets
wohin die Bälle fliegen er ist sehr viel
reifer geworden und Show ist dann
natürlich zu einer Weltklasse torter
gereift dramatisch das Ende in Köln Juri
Knorr rutscht aus der Ball gelangt aber
dennoch zu Julian Köster das 26 Z
24 der nächste Gegner Österreich die
große Überraschung bisher bei der EM gut
möglich dass Gislason auch nach diesem
Spiel wieder vorrangig seinen Torwart
adeln
darf zum Wintersport da hatte es Laura
Gimmler beim Langlauf Weltcup in Oberhof
im Sprint klassisch bis ins Finale
geschafft drei Schweden Land landeten
auf dem Podest die oberdorferin wurde
Fünfte ja und beim Biathlon Weltcup in
anthol zeigte Vanessa Fogt erneut eine
starke Leistung sie wurde Vierte im
Einzel über 12,5
km bangen im Zielraum Vanessa erlebt den
Einlauf der frzo diese schnappt dir um
5,8 Sekunden den dritten Podestplatz des
Winters Weg das nehme ich heute gerne
mit auch wenn es nicht fürs Podium
gereicht hat bin ich den noch sehr
zufrieden vier fehlerfreie
Schießeinlagen sind die Basis läuferisch
fehlt noch ein wenig zum Niveau der
allerbesten die überraschungssiegerin
Lena hecky groß aus der Schweiz
ebenfalls fehlerfrei feiert ihren ersten
Weltcupsieg sie gewinnt vor Julia Simon
aus
Frankreich und das war's auch schon vom
Sport vielen Dank
in dieser Woche sorgte das Witter
Winterwetter vieler Orts für Chaos heute
zeigte es sich von seiner schönsten
Seite am Fichtelberg im Erzgebirge
dürften sich Wintersportler über ideale
Bedingungen freuen und auch an der Elbe
erstrahlte die Landschaft in
weiß und es bleibt auch so morgen wird's
noch mal richtig sonnig allerdings nach
einer ziemlich eisigen Nacht mehr dazu
gleich beim Wetter von östen terli Mari
begrüßt sie um 22 Uhr im heutejournal
und das komplette heuteeteam wünscht
Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen schönen guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter die
extremen Wetter der letzten Tage
brachten eine Menge Schnee und auch Eis
und sie sehen hier in Weiß bis nach
Frankreich wo die Luftmassengrenze lag
und wenn man den Film laufen lässt sehen
Sie wie die Wolken drüberziehen was
übrig bleibt ist hier der Schnee und
außerdem gab es heute viel Sonnenschein
in der Nacht gibt's ganz im Norden viele
Wolken es regnet und schneit bei einem
kräftigen Westwind sonst kllar es auf es
bildet sich teilweise Nebel es gibt
strengen Frost ganz im Süden bei -18 -
im Westen frostfrei ganz im Norden bei 1
bis 3° morgen dann ganz im Norden wieder
wieder dicht bewölkt und kräftiger Wind
aus West sonst Sonnenschein in der Mitte
und im Süden aber in den Tälern hält
sich teilweise der Nebel länger
vielleicht auch den ganzen Tag und das
bei höchsten Temperaturen dann -3 also
bei Dauerfrost und 6° ganz im Norden
deutlich milder die nächsten Tage am
Sonntag noch relativ ruhig im Norden
Regen hier kommt allerdings dann
durchaus heftiger Wind auf -1 bis 7°
kein Vergleich zum Montag dann erwartet
uns ein Sturmtief und es wird deutlich
milder bis 11° einen schönen Abend